jetzt
sind wir angekommen beim Antrag der
Unionsfraktion den ich eben eben schon
geschildert habe erster Rednerin wird
sein Andrea Lindholz stellvertretende
Vorsitzende der Unionsfraktion und wie
gesagt es geht um den Umgang mit
klimaprotestland die straßenblockieren
und in Museen eindringen und
Gemälde bewerfen mit beispielsweise
Kartoffelbrei oder Tomatensaft die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin er mahnt noch
mal jetzt doch hier langsam im
Plenarsaal zur Ruhe zu kommen das ist ja
auch eine Frage des Respekts gegenüber
den Rednerinnen und Redner hier im
Plenum Abstimmung muss auch sein aber
das kann man eigentlich alles in allem
durchaus koordiniert hinbekommen jetzt
Andrea Lindholz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Ende August
klebten sich zwei sogenannte
klimaaktivisten in Dresden an Rafael
Sixtinische Madonna aus dem Jahr 1512
Mitte Oktober bewarfen eine Frau und ein
Mann in Potsdam das Gemälde
getreideschober von Claude Monet aus dem
Jahr 1890 mit Kartoffelbrei am 31
Oktober standen in Berlin wieder einmal
rettungskräfte der Feuerwehr im Stau
weil sich Mitglieder einer Protestgruppe
auf der Stadtautobahn festgeklebt hatten
die Rettungskräfte waren auf dem Weg zu
einer Radfahrerin die nach einem Unfall
in Lebensgefahr schwebte und einige Tage
später leider verstarb unser Mitgefühl
gilt an dieser Stelle den Angehörigen
der 44-Jährigen insbesondere ihrer
Zwillingsschwester
wir wissen nicht ob das Leben der
Radlerin hätte gerettet werden können
aber laut dem Bericht der Berliner
Feuerwehr wäre zumindest eine
patientenschonende Rettung möglich
gewesen
das sind nur einige Beispiele für den
immer radikaleren Protest von Teilen der
klimaschutzbewegung in den vergangenen
Wochen und Monaten und ich will es
gleich zu Beginn in aller Klarheit sagen
das ist kein politischer Aktivismus mehr
das sind Straftaten
gezielt wird unser nationales Kulturgut
angegriffen und beschädigt gezielt
kleben sich Menschen auf Autobahnen und
an Verkehrsknotenpunkten auf der Straße
fest weil sie mit einer möglichst lang
anhaltenden Blockade von möglichst
vielen Menschen möglichst viel
Aufmerksamkeit erreichen wollen das hat
nichts mehr mit den einfachen
Sitzblockaden auf den Zufahrtsstraßen
nach Wackersdorf oder Gorleben zu tun
hier werden im Stau stehende Bürgerinnen
und Bürger instrumentalisiert zum Teil
wird Leib und Leben gefährdet oder wie
in diesem Fall eine nichtrettung
billigend in Kauf genommen seit Februar
wurden durch die Blockaden allein hier
in Berlin 18 Rettungsfahrzeuge im
Einsatz behindert und ich hoffe wir sind
uns hier alle einig das ist nicht
akzeptabel
und um es gerade auch in dieser um es
gerade in dieser Woche in der in Ägypten
die UN-Klimakonferenz stattfindet auch
ganz klar zu sagen der Schutz unserer
natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen ist eine
zentrale Aufgabe unserer Zeit vielleicht
ist sie sogar die zentrale Aufgabe und
es ist vollkommen in Ordnung für eine
andere Politik zu protestieren
Demonstrationen sie sind wichtig in
unserer Demokratie sie sind ein
wichtiges Instrument der politischen
Willensbildung viele von uns haben
selbst schon an einer Demonstration
teilgenommen das Demonstrationsrecht ist
von unserer Verfassung garantiert aber
es ist doch ganz klar weder der
Klimaschutz noch das Demonstrationsrecht
rechtfertigen Straftaten rechtfertigen
zunehmende Radikalisierung rechtfertigen
die Gefährdung von Menschen durch
Straßenblockaden die Behinderung von
Rettungskräften und die gezielte
Beschädigung historischer Kunstwerke
hier werden rote Linien überschritten
[Applaus]
und unser Rechtsstaat er hat hierauf
bislang keine ausreichenden Antworten
gefunden es wurde vor allem Geldstrafen
verhängt aber mit Geldstrafen werden wir
diese zunehmende Radikalisierung in
diesem Bereich nicht aufhalten
Täter müssen den Unwert ihrer Taten
nicht nur finanziell sondern auch durch
den möglichen Freiheitsentzug spüren und
aus Sicht der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion sollen daher
Straßen blockiere die die Durchfahrt von
Polizei Feuerwehr und Rettungskräften
behindern oder billigend in Kauf nehmen
künftig statt einer Geldstrafe auch eine
mindestfreiheitsstrafe drohen und zu
diesem Zweck wollen wir den Strafrahmen
bei einem besonders schweren Fall der
Nötigung und bei einem gefährlichen
Eingriff in den Straßenverkehr auf
Freiheitsstrafe zwischen mindestens drei
Monaten und fünf Jahren anheben und auch
für die Beschädigung und Zerstörung von
bedeutenden Kulturgütern soll in Zukunft
eine mindestfreiheitsstrafe von drei Mon
statt wie bisher nur eine Geldstrafe
gelten
das ist ein Zeichen dass das Parlament
der Gesetzgeber setzen kann und wir sind
dafür hier auch ein Zeichen zu setzen
[Applaus]
ich möchte aber zum Schluss meine Rede
mit einem Appell angeradet die Menschen
beenden die diese inakzeptablen
Straftaten in Museen und auf der Straße
vornehmen und auch an die Menschen die
mit denen die sich radikalisieren
mitlaufen sei es wissentlich oder
unwissentlich
Klimaschutz ist wichtig aber er
rechtfertigt keine Straftaten deswegen
sage ich nutzen Sie bitte die
Instrumente der Demokratie zerstören Sie
nicht unser Kulturgut gefährden sie
nicht Leib und Leben anderer Menschen
blockieren sie keine Rettungskräfte und
Rettungsfahrzeuge denn am Ende erreicht
man mit solchen Straftaten nur eines man
schadet dem wichtigen Ziel des
Klimaschutzes selbst und Klimaschutz
muss im Vorrang stehen und keine
inakzeptablen Straftaten und deshalb
bitte ich auch unserem Antrag
zuzustimmen um ein Zeichen zu setzen
sagt Andrea Lindholz die
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
cdu/csu-fraktion die eben diesen Antrag
den sie gerade begründet hat hier
eingebracht hat nächste Rednerin wird
Sonja eichwede sein sie ist
rechtspolitische Sprecherin der
SPD-Fraktion
wegen der demokratischen Fraktion die
Bewältigung der Klimakrise ist eines der
wichtig eine der wichtigsten
gesellschaftlichen Aufgaben unserer Zeit
und aus diesem Grund nimmt sie in
politischen Debatten und auch in
politischen Entscheidungen der letzten
Jahre sehr sehr großen Raum ein das
erklärte Ziel der AktivistInnen der
letzten Generation aber ist die
Erzeugung von Aufmerksamkeit und die
Störung dies hat nichts mit Klimaschutz
zu tun hier muss unser Rechtsstaat mit
allen zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln
konsequent handeln es gibt viele Wege
sich in der Demokratie und der Politik
an der politischen Meinungsbildung zu
beteiligen die Gefährdung der
öffentlichen Sicherheit und Ordnung und
die Begehung von Straftaten ist
selbstverständlich kein legitimes
prozessmittel das hat hier auch keiner
im Hause angezweifelt ein Fernziel
ein Fernseh wie der Klimaschutz
rechtfertigt sich nicht durch ein
konkretes zahlziel der Störung des
Straßenverkehrs oder eben der
Sachbeschädigung das vorweggenommen aber
kommen wir zum vorliegenden Antrag der
Unionsfraktion zu dem ich auch als
ehemalige Strafrichterin einige wichtige
Punkte sagen muss denn dieser zeugt von
einem populistischen Ruf nach
strafrechtlichen Verschärfungen der
weder den Ermittlungsbehörden hilft noch
weitere Straftaten verhindern könnte
erzeugt lediglich
erzeugt die lediglich von rechtlicher
und ebenso auch von tatsächlicher
Unkenntnis und viel schlimmer noch er
vermittelt den Eindruck dass unser
Rechtsstaat nicht handlungsfähig wäre
das ist falsch und es ist ebenso
fahrlässig
unser Straftat bietet zahlreiche
Möglichkeiten konsequent durchzugreifen
einige Tatbestände sprechen sie in ihrem
Antrag auch an in Betracht kommt die
Nötigung mit einer Freiheitsstrafe von
drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe der
gefährliche Eingriff in den
Straßenverkehr mit einer strafänderung
von einer Freiheitsstrafe bis zu fünf
Jahren oder Geldstrafe und die gemeinen
schädliche Sachbeschädigung ebenso mit
einer Freiheitsstrafe von bis zu drei
Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe also
Freiheitsstrafen sind jedoch möglich
wenn sie tat und Schuld angemessen sind
und gerade bei Straßen blockieren ist
seit langem höchstricherlich entschieden
dass durch die Verursachung eines Staus
aufgrund von physischer und psychischen
Straßenblockaden die dadurch entstehen
der Tatbestand der Nötigung einschlägig
ist und dass die Beschmutzung von
Gegenständen die das Erscheinungsbild
erheblich verändern einen
gemeinschaftliche Sachbeschädigung sind
diese Tatbestände sind anwendbar hier
wird auch zu ermittelt und die lagen
auch schon einige Urteile aus den
beschriebenen Taten vor das heißt der
Rechtsstaat handelt zu einem weiteren
Punkt ihres antragsbestimmung des
Strafmaßes und die Frage der Aussetzung
der Bewährung ist auch hier schon die
Handlung gegeben die wir haben denn das
erheblich rücksichtslose Vorgehen der
letzten Generation zum Beispiel ebenso
wie in anderen Fällen gegenüber anderen
Verkehrsteilnehmern wird strafschärfen
bereits jetzt
berücksichtigt ebenso ist die Begehung
einer Straftat unterlaufener Bewährung
eines der wichtigsten
Entscheidungskriterien gegen eine
weitere laufende Bewährung auch ich
musste als Strafrichterin solche
Entscheidungen treffen aber die
strafrichterinnen und Strafrecht da
können doch am besten gucken ob noch
eine positive Sozialprognose vorliegt
oder nicht das ist nicht Sache der
Politik
all dies ist durch die erkennen in
Richter zu beurteilen ich fasse zusammen
der vorliegende Antrag aber zeugt von
einem mir unerklärlichen und gar
respektlosen Misstrauen gegenüber unsere
Justiz und gegenüber der Fähigkeit
unserer Richterinnen und Richter Tat und
Schuld angemessene Entscheidungen zu
treffen verehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Unionsfraktion dieses
Misstrauen hätte ich gerade von ihnen
nicht erwartet
aber aus welchem Grunde wollen Sie denn
sonst nur die Mindeststrafen
entsprechend hochsetzen abgesehen davon
ist schon lange wissenschaftlich belebt
das härtere Straftaten nicht abstrecken
und außerdem zwingt es mich bei ihrem
Antrag auch zu betonen das besonders
harte Strafen in einem Rechtsstaat nicht
gegen einen einzelnen Täter verhängt
werden können um quasi weitere
potenzielle Täter abzuschrecken Exempel
zu statuieren ist kein Merkmal eines
rechtsstaatlichen Systems sondern einen
Merkmal von autoritären Regime und so
eines haben wir gerade nicht mit hin ist
die angebliche Stärkung unseres
Rechtsstaats in Wahrheit eines
Schwächung ihres Rechtsstaats ich bitte
Sie dieses entsprechend zu überdenken
die Höhe einer Strafe bestimmt sich nach
der Tat und der Schuld des Täters im
konkreten Einzelfall die Unterstellung
entsprechende Tat nicht hart genug
verfolgt werden ist anmaßend
die Politik hat sich eben aus solchen
Entscheidungen rauszuhalten gerade der
strafzuständige Richter soll sich ein
sachgerechten Eindruck von dem
Angeklagten verschaffen und hinsichtlich
einer positiven oder negativen
Sozialprognose entscheiden und auch über
die Bewährung entscheiden aber sehr
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Unionsfraktion verdutzt hat mich in
ihrem Antrag noch ein weiterer Punkt
denn die Forderung der Erhöhung des der
Mindeststrafe auf drei Monate
Freiheitsstrafe ist doch auch quasi in
rechtlichen Termini gesprochen ein
untauglicher Versuch in der Praxis würde
diese strafschärfung nicht keine Wirkung
zeigen und auch wohl nicht zu mehr
Freiheitsstrafen führen denn § 47 StGB
sagt doch richtigerweise das
Freiheitsstrafen unter sechs Monaten nur
in unerlässlichen Ausnahmefällen zu
verhängen sind und diese ausnahmebefälle
fühlen sich nach der konkreten Tat und
Persönlichkeit des Täters und gerade
nicht nach ganzen Fallgruppen mithin
mithin würde nach § 47 Absatz 2 StGB die
Mindeststrafe von drei Monaten bei einem
Tat auch zu einer Geldstrafe führen mein
Tipp an Sie werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Unionsfraktion für kommende
rechtspolitische Anträge ein Blick ins
Gesetz erleichtert die Rechtsfindung
abschließend bleiben drei Dinge zu sagen
erstens eine echte Stärkung unserer
Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Gerichte
erreichen wir nicht durch
Strafverschärfung sondern durch
Digitalisierung Modernisierung und eine
gute Ausstattung dafür setzt sich die
Ampel ein zweitens abgesehen von
ungerechtfertigten Taten der letzten
Generation erwartet die
Zivilgesellschaft und die junge
Generation gerade zu Recht dass wir
weiter effektiven Klimaschutz betreiben
wir als SPD-Fraktion wissen dass
effektiver Klimaschutz und soziale
Gerechtigkeit zusammen gedacht werden
müssen und drittens
anstelle des Rufes nach höheren
Straftaten sollten Sie von der Union
lieber ihre politische Blockadehaltung
hinsichtlich der Frage von erneuerbaren
Energien überdenken und beispielsweise
in Bayern die 10h-regel kippen so können
wir im ganzen Land effektiven
Klimaschutz betreiben und gut
zusammenarbeiten vielen Dank
Sonja ich wede war das aus der
SPD-Fraktion wo sie rechtspolitische
Sprecherin ist und der Bundestag
diskutiert über Strafen für Straßen
Blockierer und sogenannte
museumsrandalierer das ist eine
Formulierung aus dem Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion der hier debattiert
wird und in dieser Debatte jetzt Thomas
Seitz der rechtspolitische Sprecher der
afd-fraktion
die Extremisten der letzten Generation
üben Gewalt aus und gefährden das Leben
und die Sicherheit vieler Menschen und
nehmen die Beschädigung unersetzlicher
Kultur Güter in Kauf es geht um
gezielten Rechtsbruch nicht um zivilen
Ungehorsam die grüne RF ist mitten in
der Entstehung angesichts des
zunehmenden Extremismus braucht es
dringend ein Verbot dieser Organisation
hilft bei der Bekämpfung der
klimaextremisten aber davor liegende
Antrag definitiv nein den handwerklich
schlechter geht es kaum wenn schon
Populismus dann doch bitte richtig im
Einzelnen zur Forderung nach härteren
Bestrafungen
Ausschluss von kettenbewehrungen das
hört sich hat zwar mit der Problematik
nicht wirklich zu tun hört sich aber
nach and order an da ist es wohl zu viel
verlangt auf die Systematik einzugehen
die zwischen Straftaten bis sechs
Monaten bis zu einem Jahr und von über
einem Jahr differenziert unter Ziffer 2
wollen sie Paragraph 240 Nötigung um
weitere Regelbeispiele ergänzen um
Straßen Fragen zu Anden warum aber
Blockierer mit einer Mindeststrafe von
drei Monaten bedacht werden sollen
werden die bestehenden Regelbeispiele
ein Mindeststrafe von sechs Monaten
vorsehen das erschließt sich nicht
schlimmer ist dass ihnen offenbar nicht
bewusst ist dass in der Rechtspraxis
Mindeststrafe meist regelstrafe bedeutet
erst Täter würden also niemals mehr als
drei Monate bekommen die wegen § 47 StGB
die Kollegin hat es ausgeführt in 90
Tagessätze umgewandelt würden die
Tagessatzhöhe bei dieser hier
einschlägigen Klientel wird regelmäßig
mit zehn Euro bemessen werden also 900
Euro für eine Straßenblockade das ist
keine Abschreckung und vor allem dürfte
es für die Zahlung genügend Sponsoren
geben interessant ist sie vertreiben mit
der Idee dann gefährlichen Eingriff in
den Straßenverkehr die Eignung zur
Gefährdung ausreichen zu lassen und
gleichzeitig eine Mindeststrafe von drei
Monaten einzuführen sie stufen also die
Norm vom konkreten zum abstrakten
gefährdungselekt herunter während der
schuldgehalt des Delikts abnimmt erhöhen
die Strafe zudem bringen sie das ganze
Gefüge der Paragraphen 315 bis 315c
durcheinander wenn sie aus vier
konkreten gefährdungsdelikten eines
herausgreifen und herabstufen und diese
Änderung bringt für Straßenblockaden
noch nicht einmal viel denn § 315b-sitz
eine verkehrsspezifische Gefahr voraus
die sich realisieren würde wenn
klimaverbrecher auf eine autobahnrennen
und dadurch eine massenkarombalage
verursachen tatsächlich aber wird im
städtischen Umfeld der Verkehr zum
Stillstand gebracht ohne dass es direkt
zu Unfällen kommt wenn sich ein Stau
bildet und es passieren dann
Folgeunfälle verwirklicht sich keine
verkehrsspezifische Gefahr sondern das
allgemeine Lebensrisiko das gleiche gilt
wenn ein Rettungsfahrzeug nicht durch
den Stau kommt wie letzte Woche in
Berlin
einschlägig wäre 315b nur dann wenn das
Hindernis ein ankommendes
Rettungsfahrzeug unmittelbar behindert
was in der Regel aber gerade nicht der
Fall ist
in Ziffer 4 wollen Sie
323c-absatz 2 verschärfen nur die
Vorschrift passt in den meisten Fällen
überhaupt nicht die Reihenfolge muss da
lauten Unglück rettungswilliger
Behinderung wenn man sich aber an der
Straße festklebt und es kommt erst
später zu einem Unglück ist die
Behinderung ein reiner Flex keine
taugliche taghandlung genauso wenig
durchdacht ist die Überlegung die
überein schädliche Sachbeschädigung zu
verschärfen denn wir haben gerade
gelernt Mindeststrafe drei Monate heißt
praktisch 900 Euro Geldstrafe was wäre
also zielführend eine Blockade von
Verkehrswegen bedeutet für alle die auf
ein ungestörten Verkehrsweg angewiesen
sind eine Risikoerhöhung es geht um
einen schnellen Transport ins
Krankenhaus oder das rechtzeitige
Eintreffen der Feuerwehr oder Raum zu
verhindern dass die Kinder irgendwo
hilflos vor verschlossener Türe stehen
das oftmals um Leben oder Tod geht muss
das Risiko dass die Frage der Kausalität
meist nicht mehr zu klären sein wird den
Störern auferlegt werden ohne wenn nun
aber es führt kein weg einen speziellen
Tatbestand vorbei der vor dieser
Risikoerhöhung schützt und eigentlich
müssten wir über einen
verbrechensaatbestand nachdenken um
wirklich abzuschrecken und auch um zu
verhindern dass das Verfahren wegen
geringer Schuld oder gegen Geldauflage
einfach eingestellt wird ziehen am Ende
bitte für Vandalismus in Museen gilt das
Gleiche wir sind gesprächsbereit vielen
Dank
Thomas Seitz aus der afd-fraktion
spricht von einer grünen RAF aber nimmt
damit sinngemäß eine Formulierung des
csu-landesgruppenvorsitzenden Alexander
Dobrindt der dieser Tage bei Twitter von
einer Klima RAF gesprochen hat für alle
die Jünger sind die RAF die rote
armee-fraktion war eine
linksextremistische terroristische
Vereinigung die für mindestens 33
gezielte Morde verantwortlich war unter
anderem anführungskräften aus Politik
und Wirtschaft Irene Mia Alice samt
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin
ständig unabhängig davon ob der Grund
für den protestberechtigt sein mag oder
nicht darüber haben wir in einer
Demokratie sowieso nicht zu befinden
Protest darf und soll kreativ sein und
ja Protest darf auch stören aber er
findet seine Grenzen wo Leib und Leben
von Menschen gefährdet werden oder die
Schwelle zu Straftaten überschritten
wird meine Damen und Herren und
es wird auch nicht besser wenn Proteste
unter dem Label Klimaschutz laufen ganz
im Gegenteil die letzte Generation
erweist dem Klimaschutz einen
Bärendienst und streut all denen Sand
ins Getriebe die sich ernsthaft und
aufrichtig für eine wirksame
Klimaschutzpolitik einsetzen denn
denn das Prinzip dass der Zweck die
Mittel heiligt können wir im Rechtsstaat
nicht akzeptieren und darüber hinaus
sind diese gefährlichen Aktionen auch
noch mit dem Blick auch noch mit Blick
auf den vermeintlichen Zweck völlig
nutzlos denn jetzt reden ja wieder alle
nur über Protestformen über das was geht
was nicht geht über Straßenblockaden
über Tomatensuppe auf Gemälden aber eben
nicht über die massiven Folgen der
Klimakrise selbst jetzt während der Cop
27 überlagern die Debatten um den
Protest die wichtigen Diskussionen und
Entscheidungen die global gegen diese
existenzielle Bedrohung der Klimakrise
stattfinden müssen und die gefährlichen
Aktionen der sogenannten letzten
Generationen sind daher in diesem Sinne
klimapolitisch kontraproduktiv sie sind
rechtsstaatlich hochproblematisch und
damit vollkommen inakzeptabel
aber jetzt komme ich
jetzt komme ich zum Antrag der Union
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
das was sie hier machen ist mindestens
genauso hart am Thema vorbei wie die
Proteste für die Sie jetzt eine
Strafverschärfung fordern sie haben ja
geradezu nur nach einer Gelegenheit
gesucht von ihrem eigenen Scheitern in
der Klimapolitik ablenken zu können
indem sie jetzt nicht nur die letzte
Generation sondern gleich die gesamte
klimaschutzbewegung diffamieren sowie
Herr Dobrindt im Konzert mit Herrn Seitz
wie wir gerade alle hören konnten von
einer Klima RAF spricht damit Herr
Dobrindt ja stellen Sie nicht nur alle
in den Senkel die sich ernsthaft und
gewaltfrei für mehr Klimaschutz
einsetzen sondern sie stellen die Opfer
von vorsätzlichem Mord und brutalem
Terrorismus in eine Reihe mit
Autofahrern die im Stau stehen das kann
doch nicht ihr Ernst sein Herr Dobrindt
das ist eine unerträgliche Verharmlosung
des Terrors der RAF und eine
Verunglimpfung der Opfer unter
Hinterbliebenen dafür sollten Sie sich
in Grund und Boden schämen
Frage des Kollegen gerne zu Ende führen
und dabei wo wir gerade bei Gedanken
sind ja wo wir gerade bei Gedanken sind
Herr Dobrindt sie denken
ja was sie hier im Kern fordern ja denn
was heißt denn das was sie in ihrem
Antrag schreiben für die Traktoren Demos
von Landwirten ja die zweifellos auch
eine Sicherheitsgefährdung darstellen
sollen die jetzt etwa alle in den Knast
wenn Sie den Verkehr der halben Republik
lahmlegen nein da sind sie ganz
solidarisch und pflegen ihre doppelten
Standards im Sinne einer so wie es
gerade passt Partei aber dabei legen sie
selber die Axt an den Rechtsstaat den
sie angeblich schützen wollen und
deswegen sage ich Ihnen deswegen sage
ich Ihnen ganz klar Proteste die Leib
und Leben von Menschen gefährden sind
inakzeptabel und zwar völlig unabhängig
vom Zweck der Rechtsstaat hat alles
Nötige um effektiv dagegen vorzugehen
ihre peinlichen
strafverschärfungsförderung brauchen wir
da nicht wenn sie was kluges fordern
wollen machen Sie mal mehr Vorschläge
für ein verbesserten Klimaschutz oder
für eine kluge Verkehrspolitik damit
könnten sie der Gesellschaft auch etwas
zurückgeben was sie letzten 16 Jahre
nicht hinbekommen haben vielen Dank
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Alexander Dobrindt verzichtet auf eine
kurze Intervention er hatte ja um eine
wollte eine Zwischenfrage stellen in der
Rede von Irene miavic sein wird
das jetzt bitte tun und zu einer
Kurzintervention gebe ich das Wort dem
Kollegen doch haben wir nicht gesehen
jetzt spricht er doch
[Applaus]
liebe Frau Kolleginnen Michalitsch wenn
sie mich schon zitieren wollen was vom
Grundsatz her ja sinnvoll sein kann dann
versuchen Sie es doch aber auch richtig
zu machen wörtliches Zitat die
Entstehung einer Klima RAF muss
verhindert werden liebe Frau Kollegin
ist Ihnen bekannt die Einschätzung von
Bettina Röhl der Tochter von Ulrike
meinhoff die wörtlich gesagt hat die
letzte Generation ist schon auf der
Ziellinie zur RAF weiter sind sie mit
mir der Meinung dass die Entstehung
einer Klima RAF verhindert werden muss
ja oder nein oder was muss passieren
damit sie sich diese Einschätzung
anschließen
[Applaus]
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Dobrindt
hier eins Zusammenhang zu konstruieren
ja zwischen den abscheulichen Taten der
RAF des Terrorismus ja und das was wir
hier auf der Straßen erleben ist schon
ungeheuerlich ja ist ungeheuerlich und
Sie können es nicht weg relativieren sie
können es jetzt auch hier mit dem was
sie hier gerade gesagt haben nicht weg
relativieren diesen Zusammenhang diesen
Zusammenhang haben sie hergestellt und
dann müssen sie sich auch damit
auseinandersetzen dass das im Kern eine
Verunglimpfung und der Opfer des
Terrorismus ist und eine Verharmlosung
des brutalen Terrorismus den die RAF
über dieses Land gebracht hat und wenn
sie sich schon mit der Vergangenheit
beschäftigen und auch Zeitzeugen hier
zitieren ja dann können sich ja
vielleicht mal mit den Familien der
Opfer der RAF beschäftigen und mal
fragen was die davon halten wenn Sie die
Opfer wenn Sie zum Beispiel Familie
Herrhausen könnten sie mal fragen ja
wenn Sie die Opfer der RAF in eine Reihe
stellen mit Leuten die im Straßenverkehr
blockiert werden ja oder die auf andere
Art und Weise beeinträchtigt werden
durch die Proteste die ja gerade
stattfinden und da können sie ja mal
fragen wie die das Finden ich glaube die
Antwort darauf zu kennen Herr Dobrindt
und deswegen bleibe ich dabei was ich
gerade gesagt habe sie können eine
solche unerträgliche Relativierung von
Terrorismus hier im Hohen Haus nicht
unwidersprochen vornehmen und deswegen
bleibe ich bei dem was ich gerade
ich komme noch mal zurück zum
Tagesordnungspunkt 10b die Abstimmung
ist jetzt vorbei und ich frage es noch
ein Mitglied des Hauses anwesend dass
die Stimme nicht abgeben konnte das ist
nicht der Fall dann schließe ich die
Abstimmung und bitte die Schriftführerin
und Schriftführer mit der Auszählung zu
beginnen das Ergebnis wird Ihnen später
bekannt gegeben und jetzt gebe ich das
Wort der Kollegin Clara Bünger für die
Fraktion Die Linke und ich sage Ihnen
meine Damen und Herren nochmal fix um
welchen Antrag es hier ging nämlich dem
der linksfraktionen mit dem Titel
Regelsätze spürbar Erhöhung 200 Euro
mehr gegen Inflation und Armut und jetzt
wie von der Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
schon angekündigt Clara Bünger
rechtspolitische Sprecherin der
Linksfraktion
ein Landtagsabgeordneter der CDU von
Öko-Terroristen Sie Herr Dobrindt
warnten vor einer klimarafe so wie es
Frau Michalitsch auch gerade gesagt
haben und durch ihre Ausführung wurde
ihre Aussage einfach auch nicht besser
und der hessische Justizminister
fabulierte über terroranklagen gegen
klimaaktivistin damit vergleichen Sie
Personen die sich für den Erhalt der
menschlichen Lebensgrundlage einsetzen
mit Verbrechern die Bomben bauen und aus
Verachtung von menschlichen Leben
Anschläge verüben wenn sie das wirklich
ernst meinten sollten Sie sich für diese
Vergleiche schämen
in ihrem Antrag geben Sie vor es ginge
ihnen um den Schutz des Lebens und der
körperlichen Unversehrtheit aber die
oben genannten Aussagen die ich gemacht
habe machen deutlich worum es ihnen
eigentlich geht die größtmöglichste
Kriminalisierung politischer
Meinungsäußerung die nicht mit ihren
eigenen übereinstimmen sie wollen
Menschen
die politisch links stehen das ist kein
demokratischer Vorschlag das sind
autoritäre Anwandlung die unsere
Debattenkultur und unsere Demokratie
ernsthaft gefährden
und ich glaube ja sie haben einfach
Angst nach 16 Jahren in der Regierung
haben sie Angst vor Bedeutungsverlust
weil sie merken dass sie keine Antworten
auf die drängenden Probleme unserer
Gesellschaft haben aber diesen Gefühl
der Unsicherheit begegnet man doch nicht
mit dem Strafrecht sondern mit eigenen
tragfähigen politischen Ideen
und auch wir haben ja ihren Antrag
gelesen wenn da mittlerweile keine
ohnehin rechtswidrige Präventivhaft mehr
drin ist und sie das nicht mehr fordern
läuft ist juristisch betrachtet auf
Quatsch Jura hinaus was sie da
formulieren so wollen sie § 240 Absatz 4
StGB um Regelbeispiele erweitern die
Teilnahme an Sitzblockaden im
Straßenverkehr soll ein besonders
schwerer Fall der Nötigung werden aber
Sitzblockaden zur politischen
Meinungsäußerung fallen nach ständiger
Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts die sehr
ausdifferenziert ist in den
Schutzbereich des Versammlungsrechts aus
Artikel 8
und wenn keine verwerfliche Nötigung
vorliegt müssen wir über eine besondere
Schwere bei der straftemessung gar nicht
reden Frau Bünger möchten Sie die
Zwischenfrage von Frau Lindholz zulassen
zu Ende bringen aber kommen wir zurück
zum Grund der Proteste Luisa Neubauer
sagte richtigerweise dass die Kritik an
den Aktionsformen der letzten Generation
nichts an der bestehenden
Klimakatastrophe ändert das sämtliche
Klimaziele die ohnehin viel zu
unambitioniert waren
nicht eingehalten werden wenn sie sich
nicht bald grundlegend etwas ändert
werden große Teile der Erde unbewohnbar
zig Millionen Menschen werden ihre
Lebensgrundlage verlieren wie wir es
dieses Jahr auch schon in Pakistan
gesehen haben sie werden sterben oder
zur Flucht getrieben statt das in den
Mittelpunkt ihres politischen Handels zu
stellen geht aber auch die Koalition auf
ihre Droge werden ein und die
Innenministerin unterstellt das
vorsätzlich Rettungswege versperrt
wurden ich kenne keine klimaaktivistin
die sich mit Vorsatz der versperrung von
Rettungswegen mit UHU auf die Straße
geklebt hat im Gegenteil wir haben im
Montag am Montag gesehen wie in Leipzig
Menschen die eine Straßenblockade
gemacht haben sofort Platz gemacht haben
als die Feuerwehr durch müsste so muss
das laufen
und der Tod der Radfahrerin ist wirklich
sehr tragisch ich denke wir alle müssen
verhindern dass Menschen im
Straßenverkehr sterben die letzte
Generation muss das tun und wir müssen
aber auch alle dafür sorgen und dann
müssen wir auch darüber diskutieren wie
wir solidarisch miteinander umgehen
rettungsgassen bilden nicht in der
zweiten Reihe parken denn 80 Prozent der
Fälle werden keine rettungsgassen
gebildet daran müssen wir etwas ändern
alle klimapro in Frage zu stellen sollte
die Bundesregierung endlich Maßnahmen
ergreifen um den Klimawandel zu stoppen
vielen Dank
Clara Bünger war das rechtspolitische
Sprecherin der Linksfraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag wir sind nach wie
vor in der Debatte über einen Antrag der
Unionsfraktion zu Strafen für Straßen
Blockierer und Museums Randalierer man
muss sagen für härtere Strafen um genau
zu sein jetzt kommt eine
Kurzintervention von Andrea Lindholz aus
Kolleg
in Zwischenfrage nicht zugelassen sie
haben in ihrer Rede zum einen von den
Gefühlen der Opfer gesprochen und zum
anderen haben Sie die klimaaktivisten
gerechtfertigt
haben Sie eigentlich das Interview der
Zwillingsschwester der Verstorbenen
Radfahrerin im Spiegel zur Kenntnis
genommen und wie stehen Sie zu dem was
die Schwester gesagt hat und was ich
Ihnen jetzt auch vorhalte über den Grund
warum sie die Öffentlichkeit sucht hat
sie gesagt weil ich in der
Berichterstattung las wie ignorant
einige klimaaktivisten den Tod von
Menschen in Kauf nehmen wie stehen Sie
zu dieser Einschätzung
Frau Bünger bitte
der Radfahrerin natürlich das tiefe
Mitgefühl mitteilen und da stehen wir
auch als Linksfraktion dafür ich finde
es wirklich ungeheuerlich wie sie das
Schicksal dieser Radfahrerin hier für
ihre politischen Zwecke
instrumentalisieren
es ist erschüttert mich ernsthaft dass
sie auch auch das so in die
Öffentlichkeit ziehen ich weiß nicht mal
ob die Familie der Radfahrerin der
Radfahrerin überhaupt selber das so
befürworten würde ich denke in diesem
Zusammenhang haben wir alle sehr viel
unterschiedliche Berichterstattungen
gesehen mit unterschiedlichen
Positionierungen wie zum Beispiel dass
die Ärztin gesagt hat dass die
Radfahrerin nicht hätte gerettet werden
können und es gibt dazu unterschiedliche
Berichte und die sind auch sehr
ausdifferenziert und was sie hier machen
ist das populistisch für ihre eigene
politischen Zwecke Zweck zu entfremden
und das halte ich für gefährlich und
auch nicht richtig und angemessen
Clara Dünger noch mal mit einer
wiederung auf eine kurze Intervention
von Andrea Lindholz und jetzt würde ich
jetzt noch einmal zurückkommen zum
Tagesordnungspunkt von vorhin weil wir
das Ergebnis der namentlichen Abstimmung
vorliegen haben zu dem Antrag der
Abgeordneten tatif herrschel birkwald
und weitere Abgeordnete Fraktion DIE
LINKE Regelsätze spürbar erhöhen 200
Euro mehr gegen Inflation und Armut auf
den Drucksachen
2040 53 und 2043 60 und die
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses für
Arbeit und Soziales wurden abgegeben 679
Stimmkarten mit ja haben bestimmt 643
mit 935 es gab eine Enthaltung mit hin
ist die Beschlussempfehlung angenommen
und jetzt kommen wir zurück zu unserer
Debatte und ich gebe jetzt das Wort an
Konstantin Kohle für die FDP und damit
haben wir den ganzen komplexen
Bürgergeld Gesetz von heute morgen
Tagesordnungspunkt 10 ist das gewesen
endgültig abgeschlossen der Antrag der
AFD also abgelehnt und wir kommen zurück
zur Debatte
zu Straßen blockieren und
museumsrandalierern Konstantin Kuhle für
die FDP-Fraktion dass sich mehr Menschen
für das Thema Klimaschutz interessieren
und engagieren die friedlichen Proteste
etwa von Fridays for future haben dazu
geführt dass ich bis in die Mitte der
Gesellschaft hinein mehr Menschen selbst
kritisch die Frage stellen tun wir als
Gesellschaft tun wir als Staat als
Gemeinwesen eigentlich genug für den
Klimaschutz und diese Geschichte diese
Errungenschaft ist etwas das friedliche
klimaproteste erreicht haben und dafür
gilt ihnen Respekt und Anerkennung meine
Damen und Herren was wir aber in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten an
Radikalisierung und an Militanz bei den
klimaprotesten erleben das bewirkt genau
das Gegenteil denn das führt dazu dass
die gesellschaftliche Mitte sich
abwendet vom Thema des Klimaschutzes die
sogenannte letzte Generation sie macht
aus dem Thema Klimaschutz ein radikales
Nischenthema und genau diese Gefahr
führt dazu dass wir weniger Klimaschutz
in der Gesellschaft haben und dass wir
weniger politische Debatten über dieses
wichtige Thema haben oder man könnte
auch sagen die Aktivisten und Aktivisten
der sogenannten letzten Generationen
reißen mit dem Hintern ein was Luisa
Neubauer und Greta Thunberg mühsam
aufgebaut haben
und wenn wir uns einmal mit der Attitüde
mit der Haltung dieser Demonstranten
auseinandersetzen dann ist diese Haltung
nicht nur im Kern antidemokratisch weil
es darum geht keinen Widerspruch keine
andere Meinung zuzulassen sie ist auch
totalitär sie ist autoritär und sie ist
von einer Herablassung geprägt die
kontraproduktiv ist denn die Leute die
da blockiert werden die Leute die nicht
zur Arbeit kommen die müsste man
eigentlich davon überzeugen das
Klimaschutz eine wichtige Sache ist aber
glaubt ihr denn im Ernst dass ein
Polizist der sich da morgens um 7 Uhr
darum kümmern muss dass euch nichts
passiert wenn ihr euch festklebt dass
eine Mitarbeiterin im ambulanten
Pflegedienst die ab 7 Uhr ab 6 Uhr die
älteren Leute pflegen will dass
diejenigen die ihren ersten Termin als
Handwerker haben um 6 Uhr um 7 Uhr
morgens dass die für mehr Klimaschutz
sind bei solchen Aktionen das Gegenteil
wird eintreten und wenn ich dann höre
das Aktivisten der sogenannten letzten
Generation ihr Studium abbrechen ihre
Ausbildung abbrechen aus Angst vor dem
Thema Klimaschutz das ist nichts anderes
als eine unerträgliche Hybris die dazu
führt dass man sich die Frage stellen
muss wer kann sich sowas eigentlich
erlauben die Menschen die ich gerade
aufgezählt habe mit einem einfachen
Einkommen mit einem durchschnittlichen
Einkommen jedenfalls nicht und deswegen
ist all das etwas was aufhören muss und
wo sich auch die gesamte Klimabewegung
radikal von abgrenzen muss liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und jetzt sind wir beim Strafrecht
und jetzt sind wir beim Strafrecht jetzt
sind wir bei einem Mittel dass das
schärfste Schwert ein Instrument dass
das ultima ratio Instrument des
Rechtsstaats ist und da muss man ganz
klar sagen hängt die Union leider der
Haltung an dass man jedes
gesellschaftliche Problem jedes neue
Phänomen automatisch mit schärferem
Strafrecht lösen kann die Realität ist
aber ganz anders das geltende Recht
sieht anders als sie hier gesagt haben
doch für die einfache Sachbeschädigung
und für die einfache Nötigung auch eine
Freiheitsstrafe vor das haben sie hier
falsch dargestellt das geltende Recht
sieht auch vor dass Straßenblockaden
eine strafbare Nötigung sein können und
zwar auch wenn die sich auf die
Versammlungsfreiheit berufen wenn
nämlich der Konnex zwischen denjenigen
die ich blockiere und dem Thema über das
ich spreche für das ich demonstriere
nicht hinreichend gegeben ist dann ist
das eine strafbare Nötigung und dann
müssen die Leute auch verurteilt werden
und zwar schnell liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
es ist außerdem es ist außerdem
geltendes Recht dass wir ein
beschleunigtes Verfahren haben bringen
wir doch mal das beschleunigte Verfahren
zum Einsatz und brauchen nicht Monate
oder Jahre bis solche Leute mal
verurteilt werden es ist außerdem
geltendes Recht dass jemand der eine
Sache kaputt macht oder der eine solche
Blockade macht für die Schäden die da
entstehen haften muss machen wir die
doch zivilrechtlich verantwortlich den
muss eine Rechnung geschickt werden
dafür dass dort Leute nicht zur Arbeit
kommen dass dort Termine nicht
wahrgenommen werden können das
Gegenstände in Museen kaputt gehen die
müssen dafür blechen damit sie merken
dass man sowas nicht macht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und das
geltende Recht
und das geltende Recht sieht auch vor
dass Richterinnen und Richter über die
Strafbarkeit entscheiden und nicht wir
hier im Deutschen Bundestag und deswegen
lehnen wir Ihren Antrag ab und werden
gerne weiter daran mitwirken genau uns
anzuschauen welche Strafurteile da in
den nächsten Wochen in den nächsten
Monaten ausgeurteilt werden lassen Sie
mich abschließend sagen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich finde es
gut wenn wir hier im Bundestag über das
Thema Klimaschutz sprechen würden ich
finde es gut dass wir darüber reden wenn
wir darüber reden ob das Wind an
Landgesetz ob der Kohleausstieg auf all
die guten Sachen die wir schon gemacht
haben in der Ampelkoalition ob das nicht
ausreicht können wir gerne drüber reden
aber die Profilneurose dieser Klima
Demonstranten die führt doch dazu dass
wir hier was Strafrecht sprechen dass
wir hier über Protestformen sprechen und
nicht über die Klimaschutzziele in der
Sache das sollten wir tun oder in diesem
Sinne lieber danke
[Applaus]
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
FDP-Fraktion ich muss ein Versprecher
korrigieren ich habe ihnen vor der Rede
von Konstantin Kuhle gesagt der Antrag
der AFD sei der namentlich abgestimmt
wurde sei jetzt abgelehnt das war
natürlich ein Antrag der Linken ich bin
hier in der Zeile verrutscht es ging um
Regelsätze spürbar erhöhen 200 € mehr
gegen Inflation und Armut das wie gesagt
einen Antrag der Linken der namentlich
ausgezählt wurde und dann auch
mehrheitlich abgelehnt jetzt haben wir
Günter Kriegs am Polt aus der
Unionsfraktion rechtspolitischer
Sprecher ist ja da Klimaschutz als die
zentrale Aufgabe unserer Zeit ansehen
ist unter 90% damit dir dieses Hauses ja
gar nicht umstritten es geht ihr aber
eben nicht um Klimaschutz in der Debatte
sondern es geht um den Rechtsstaat meine
Damen und Herren und gerade deshalb
und gerade deshalb finde ich eine Reihe
von Äußerungen aus der Bundesregierung
der letzten Wochen und Monate mindestens
irritierend so die Staatssekretärin im
Auswärtigen Amt Jennifer Morgan schon im
Sommer Zitat ist es wichtig dass man
sich engagiert auf welche Art muss jeder
für sich selbst entscheiden
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke vor
wenigen Tagen es ist absolut legitim für
seine Anliegen zu demonstrieren und
dabei auch Formen des zivilen
Ungehorsams zu nutzen meine Damen und
Herren halten sie in der Ampel denn
wirklich so wenig von ihrer eigenen
Klimapolitik dass sie jede Form von
militantem Protest dagegen richtig und
akzeptabel finden
ein Bekenntnis
ein Bekenntnis zum Rechtsstaat gibt es
nur ungeteilt wer auf dem Boden des
Rechtsstaats stehen will kann nicht
zwischen guten und schlechten Straftaten
unterscheiden wir verlangen deshalb
eine schärfen des rechtsunabhängig von
den politischen Zielen die Straßen
blockiere oder museumsrand der Lehrer
verfolgen und ich bin im übrigen auch
nicht ganz sicher ob weite Teile der
Ampel noch so gelassen blieben und sagen
das ist eigentlich gar kein Thema
strafschärfung wenn diese sogenannten
Protestformen von reichsbürgern oder
rechtsradikalen kommen würden meine
Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
denn wenn wir sehen in unseren Städten
zurzeit eine ganz neue Dimension
strafwürdige Aktionen für die Blockierer
die sich auf unseren Straßen eben nicht
hinsetzen sondern festkleben ist im
Behinderung von autofahrrädern nicht
eine unvermeidbare kurzfristige
Nebenfolge ihres Tuns sondern sie wollen
gerade möglichst langanhaltende
Behinderungen möglichst vieler
Bürgerinnen und Bürger weil sie ihrem
Drang nach Aufmerksamkeit alles andere
unterordnen sie instrumentalisieren und
schädigen tausende von Unbeteiligten
und besonders bitter ist das wenn
dadurch wie wir eben auch gehört haben
Rettungskräfte im Stau stecken bleiben
und mutwillig Menschenleben gefährdet
werden die Demonstrationsfreiheit ist
ein sehr hohes Gut im Verfassungsstaat
aber eben kein Freibrief um andere quasi
in Geiselhaft für die eigenen
politischen Ziele zu nehmen
eine neue Qualität erreichen die
Proteste aber auch mit den vorsätzlichen
Sachbeschädigungen an Kunst und Kultur
und die Kollegin schenderlein wird ja
gleich noch zu sprechen es macht auch
mich aber fassungslos wenn die Täter
tatsächlich Achse zuckend in Kauf nehmen
das Kunstwerke von bedeutendem
historischen und künstlerischen Wert
durch ihr Tun und wiederbringlich
zerstört werden können und auch hier
Ziele die Taten direkt gegen Bürgerinnen
und Bürger gegen Museumsbesucher dich
unterhalten wollen die sich bilden
wollen in Museen sie müssen erleben die
Museen werden tagelang geschlossen
Museumsbesucher müssen sich inzwischen
immer mehr aufwendigen peniblen
Sicherheitskontrollen unterziehen
manchen hier im Haus mag das egal sein
aber wir wollen dass die abschreckende
Wirkung des Strafrechts so groß ist dass
unsere Museen offene Orte bleiben und
nicht in hochsicherheitstrakte
verwandelt werden müssen meine
damit und wenn wir nicht wollen dass die
beschriebenen Aktionen immer mehr
Nachahmer finden und wenn wir eine Sicht
durchaus Abzeichen des Spirale der
Radikalisierung durchbrechen wollen dann
müssen wir im Strafrecht ein klares
Signal geben es ist gut dass es in
einigen Fällen inzwischen Urteile gibt
viele Menschen verstehen aber nicht dass
die Täter bislang mit oft sehr geringen
Geldstrafen davon kommen es gibt sogar
Freisprüche teilweise und ich wiederum
kann diese Menschen verstehen
und der Verweis auf richterliche
Spielräume für höhere Strafen hilft hier
nun wirklich nicht weiter weder Urteil
Schelte noch ein öffentliches einfordern
härterer Strafen halte ich für die
angemessene Reaktion die einzig richtige
Antwort der Politik hier im Bundestag
ist vielmehr die Vorlage
gesetzgeberische erinnerungsvorschläge
und genau diese Vorschläge machen wir
mal Damen und Herren
wir wollen daher massive
Straßenblockaden künftig als besonders
schwere Feld der Nötigung einordnen
dadurch mindest Freiheitsstrafe von
sechs Monaten um Kunst und Kulturgüter
von bedeutendem Wert besser zu schützen
wollen wir stellen Strafrahmen für die
gemeinschaftliche Sachbeschädigung
erhöhen und ich bin ein drittes Beispiel
nennen besonders verwerflich erscheint
es mir wenn Personen die als
Rettungskräfte Hilfe leisten wollen
behindert werden auf sich natürlich der
Opfer aber auch aus Sicht der
Rettungskräfte diese rettungskräfte
haben es wahrlich in ihrer Arbeit
täglich schwer genug und sie haben daher
Anspruch auf einen besseren
strafrechtlichen Schutz ihrer Arbeit
und meine Damen und Herren am Ende
leitet uns die klare Überzeugung ein
noch so guter Zweck kann im Rechtsstaat
kein kriminelles Mittel Heiligen und
auch für selbsternannte Klimaschützer
kann es keinen strafrabatt geben vielen
herzlichen Dank
der rechtspolitische Sprecher der
unionsfraktionen in der Debatte über
einen Antrag der Unionsfraktion zu
härteren Strafen für Straßen Blockierer
und sogenannte Museums Randalierer jetzt
Sebastian Fiedler aus der SPD-Fraktion
wo er Sprecher für Kriminalpolitik ist
Damen und Herren ich versuche jetzt mal
nicht direkt über jede Stöckchen zu
springen sondern erstmal noch mal Ansatz
zu machen ich hatte nämlich eine
persönliche Begegnung wir haben am 11
Oktober hier mit der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion hier im
Paul-Löbe-Haus eine tolle Veranstaltung
gemacht nämlich zur Umweltkriminalität
und kurz vor Ende der Veranstaltung hat
tatsächlich einer von der sogenannten
letzten Generation der Brandmelder
eingewemmst und wir mussten den ganzen
Laden evakuieren ich habe mich ehrlich
gesagt ein bisschen gewundert dass die
Union auf diese Teilaspekte die hier im
Hause stattgefunden haben mit keiner
Silber eingegangen ist finde ich
einigermaßen bemerkenswert ich will aber
auf den eigentlichen Zusammenhang kommen
denn es ist natürlich kein
intellektueller höhlenflug wenn man sich
sozusagen für Klima und Artenschutz
einsetzt und dann ausgerechnet zu diesem
Thema eine Veranstaltung sprengt worum
geht es nämlich da es geht um das
drittgrößte kriminalitätsphänomen der
Welt
die Schätzung gehen so zwischen 100 bis
200 300 Milliarden Euro so genau weiß
man es nicht ich zitiere den WWF wir
befinden uns im größten Artensterben
seit dem Ende der dinosaurierzeit vor 65
Millionen Jahren ein Viertel der
Säugetierarten jede achte Vogelart 30
Prozent der Haie und Rochen 40 Prozent
der Amphibienarten sind bedroht und ich
ergänze einen Großteil davon ist
deswegen bedroht weil es sich um große
Kriminalitätsform handelt die ist ein
großer Treiber ein paar
Teilaspekte will ich aufgliedern
illegaler Holzhandel und Holzeinschlag
aus dem Medien wissen wir dass unsere
schöne Gorch Fock mit höchster
Wahrscheinlichkeit aus blutigem Holz aus
illegal aus Myanmar wieder
zusammengeschustert worden ist während
wir hier gerade reden in jeder Minute
gehen etwa ein Fußballfeld Regenwald der
Rodung zum Opfer das heißt wir reden
über
680 Fußballfelder während dieser Debatte
es geht um illegale Fischerei viel davon
landet auf unseren Tellern dabei geht es
um Sklavenhandel der dort betrieben wird
es geht um Wilderei
illegalen artenhandel illegalen Handel
mit Müll und dessen entsorgen illegaler
Bergbau und so weiter und so weiter das
alles ist verbunden mit Kernthemen die
wir diskutieren Lieferketten Korruption
Geldwäsche hinweisgeberschutz und vieles
mehr und deswegen und das war Thema der
Veranstaltung hat die
bundesinnenministerin angekündigt sie
wird eine Bundeszentrale ansprech- und
Koordinierungsstelle auf Ebene des
Bundes einrichten übrigens kleiner
Hinweis an die CDU in
Nordrhein-Westfalen eine Stelle die sie
dort aufgelöst haben wir richten das auf
Bundesebene ein
[Applaus]
und es wird das hat sie ebenfalls
deutlich gemacht aus den gerade
naheliegenden Gründen die ich gerade
gesagt habe ein wesentlicher Teil der
Strategie zur Bekämpfung der
organisierten Kriminalität hat nancifer
richtigerweise gesagt wird sich mit der
Bekämpfung der Umweltkriminalität
beschäftigen und wir tun alle gut daran
wenn wir die Beratung auf europäischer
Ebene konstruktiv begleiten hier im Haus
und ich gucke ich komme auf
ihr Tage machen sich keine Sorge und ich
bin mal sehr gespannt wenn es darum geht
die Kriminellen schärfer zu bestrafen
und auch die Unternehmen die sich daran
beteiligen auf europäischer Ebene hier
zu Harmonisierung zu kommen bin ich sehr
auf Ihre Hinweise dazu bekannt gespannt
genauso wie zu denen wenn wir darüber
diskutieren ob die europäische
Staatsanwaltschaft mehr
mandatsbereiche hier bekommen muss
warum spreche ich das alles an und das
geht auch natürlich in Richtung all
derjenigen die sich aus guten Gründen
fürs Klima und für Artenschutz
engagieren wir tun viel und wir packen
sogar Themen an die noch gar nicht auf
der öffentlichen Tagesordnung angekommen
waren also wir tun gut daran viel
gemeinsam zu tun und das geht an all
diejenigen die legal demonstrieren
pushen Sie auch bitte dieses Thema mit
denn eins gehört noch dazu gesagt weder
die Bundesregierung noch dieses Haus
lässt sich erpressen wenn man sozusagen
auf den Wortlaut der Homepage der
sogenannten Generation schaut dann kommt
man nämlich so ein bisschen zu diesem
Eindruck denn diese Aktion das muss ich
nicht alles wiederholen sind sehr
gefährlich für Menschenleben sie sind
strafbar sie bedrohen einzigartige
Kulturgüter und das hatten sie
dummerweise vergessen sie bedrohen die
demokratie-prozesse hier im Haus wenn
der Brandmelder geht und wir alle auf
die Straße müssen ist das durchaus ein
wesentliches Thema und es ist eine
völlig fehlgeleitete Energie denn wir
müssen wenn wir hier was erreichen
wollen alle gesellschaftlichen Kräfte
tatsächlich zusammenkriegen denn diese
Botschaft muss auch hier ausgehen die
Bedrohungen sind real und diese
Bedrohung machen Angst das darf man
durchaus dazu sagen all diejenigen die
sich hier demokratisch beteiligen die
Ziele sind richtig die Mittelgrund
falsch und sie sind eben auch kriminell
und jetzt ganz am Ende sie merken warum
ich mir die Redezeit so aufgeteilt habe
erstens haben Konstantin Kohle die
Kollegin eichwede viele andere schon
viele zu den Inhalt Ihres Antrags gesagt
man kann auch sagen Kriminologie
kriminalstrategie erste Semester also
wenn Sie hier den Leuten erzählen wollen
durch irgendeine erhöhte strafanterung
würde sich jemand nicht festkleben oder
keinen Kartoffelbrei irgendwo drauf
schmeißen ist das so ein populistischer
Unfug sondergleichen das weiß jeder der
ein bisschen Kriminologie gelesen hat
und und ob sie da beim Wort zu nehmen
weil sie ja gerne law and order Partei
sind wenn wir hier in den nächsten
Wochen und Monaten darüber diskutieren
die Strafen für Verbrecher zu erhöhen
dann werde ich sie beim Wort nehmen und
wenn es auch darum geht diese
Unternehmen die hier illegales Holz
einschleppen mit schärferen
unternehmenssanktionen zu kriegen wenn
es darum geht sie umsatzabhängig zu
machen dann bin ich gespannt wie ihr law
and order Politik bei diesem Verbrechern
aussieht das gehört nämlich mit zur
Vollständigkeit und entwickelten
konsistentes Bild
Sebastian Fiedler aus der
SPD-Fraktion richtet den Blick auch auf
den Aspekt
Umweltkriminalität
und hier kommt jetzt Stefan Brandner aus
der afd-fraktion Mitglied im
Rechtsausschuss
[Applaus]
meine Damen und Herren frau Präsidentin
von allgemeinem SPD Blabla wieder zum
Thema seit ca einem Jahr machen ihre
Klima Kleber und Museums Randalierer
vielen von uns das Leben schwer
blockierte Straßen blockierte Autobahnen
und Brücken beschmutzte besudelte
Kunstdenkmäler und Kunstwerke Sabotage
und nun in Berlin die erste Tote was
viele Orts und auch hier von ganz links
bis zur cdu-lange mit Aktivisten
niedlich umschrieben wurde ist nichts
anderes meine Damen und Herren als
klimatterrorismus in seiner reinsten
Form eine kriminelle Clique die
tatsächlich Terror verbreitet also
ideologisch motivierte Gewaltaktionen
gegen Sachen und Menschen und um um und
Unsicherheit und Angst und Schrecken zu
verbreiten taurierten darum geht es hier
und um nichts anderes das sind
klimaterroristen die sich offenbar und
da hat der Dobrind gar nicht so unrecht
die sich offenbar an die RF die in den
70er und 80er Jahren gemordet hat und
eine Wurzel der heutigen Grünen erklären
die sich offenbar diese Leute zum
Vorbild genommen haben denn auch die
damaligen Terroristen wurden zunächst
von Intellektuellen gefördert von
anderen belächeln übten zuerst zivilen
Ungehorsam aus radikalisierten sich dann
übten Gewalt gegen Sachen Brandstiftung
und am Ende Morde aus Morde auch an
völlig unbeteiligten die beispielsweise
Polizeibeamten die heutigen
klimaterroristen haben angekündigt
weiter eskalieren zu wollen ist also nur
eine Frage der Zeit bis nicht mehr
geklebt sondern abgefackelt und
vorsätzlich getötet wird und dem muss
Einhalt geboten werden
hinter der Organisation dieser letzten
Generation stehen mattiöse Strukturen
die Finanzierung läuft im Wesentlichen
über den climate emergency Front und
über der über Millionenbeträge verfügt
aber auch sie alle haben dann natürlich
Dreck am Stecken denn die letzten
Bundesregierungen und das sind ja nun
mal nahezu sie alle haben diese
Gruppierung in den letzten Jahren
Jahrzehnten Methoden Millionenbeträgen
gefördert die klimatterroristen und die
Umfeld Stichworte Kampf gegen Rechts
Demokratie Förderung Zivilgesellschaft
Antifa wokismus das ist alles der
Nährboden auf dem jetzt der
klimatterrorismus entstanden ist und
warum haben Sie das gemacht um sich das
Wohlwollen der Klima Terroristen zu
sichern und es für ihre Zwecke zunächst
zu nutzen meine Damen und das erinnert
alles so ein bisschen an den
Zauberlehrling und den Satz die Geister
die ich rief werde ich nicht mehr los
und ihr Geister die sie nun nicht mehr
loswerden haben sie alle selber gerufen
alle von diesen Klima Terroristen
draußen sind Merkel und ihren clarkeuren
in den 16 letzten 10 15 Jahren
sozialisiert sie tragen sie zumindest
moralische Verantwortung für alle
Straftaten die draußen von
klimatterroristen verübt werden meine
Damen und Herren und nun ausgerechnet
wurde
rechnet sie von der C
du oberlehrling sozusagen sie wollen die
Brut die auf ihre Politik zurückgeht die
Geister also die sie gerufen haben durch
hektische Änderungen in
Strafprozessordnung und Strafgesetzbuch
ändern das ist Heuchelei pur ich kann
mir heuchlerisches nicht vorstellen ein
klassischer CDU-Antrag
oppositionspopulismusantrag der jetzt
Gott sei Dank in den Ausschuss verwiesen
wird und ich hoffe dass von dem ganzen
Spuk den sie in diesen Antrag
reingepackten am Ende nur ganz ganz
wenig am besten gar nichts über bleibt
vielen Dank Redezeit ist vorbei
Stefan Brandner war das für die
afd-fraktion auf ihn folgt nun
Helge Limburg der rechtspolitische
Sprecher für Bündnis 90 die Grünen im
Deutschen Bundestag
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Brandner
zum einen die Behauptung meine Fraktion
der Partei hätte Wurzeln im Terrorismus
ist verleugnerisch und abwegig und zum
zweiten der Brandner es ist sehr
bezeichnend dass in Zeiten in denen in
diesem Land wieder Wohnheime von
geflüchteten angezündet werden in den
Menschen die aus der Ukraine zu uns
flüchten und Schutz suchen von
rechtsextremen Gewalttätern bedroht
werden die sich durch ihre Parolen
ermutigt und bestärkt fühlen dass sie in
diesen Zeiten versuchen gegen die
klimaerwehung zu hetzen sie lenken ab
von dem Untaten die ihrer Ideologie
entwächst
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
2021 kam insgesamt zehn RadfahrerInnen
im Berliner Straßenverkehr ums Leben
2022 bislang 9 darunter die Person die
Jungs von einem Betonmischer überfahren
wurde das sind nicht nur erschreckende
Zahlen das sind Menschen die aus dem
Leben gerissen werden und die Angehörige
in tiefer Trauer hinterlassen ihnen gilt
unser Mitgefühl wenn öffentlich darüber
gesprochen wird welche Konsequenzen aus
diesen Unfällen zu ziehen sind dann ist
Pietät gefragt und ich kann in der Tat
gut nachvollziehen dass die Schwester
der jüngst überfahrenen Radfahrer in
diese Pet ein Mindestmaß an Mitgefühl
bei einigen öffentlichen Äußerungen der
Gruppe letzte Generation vermisst hat
Angehörige von Toten sollten nicht noch
durch Äußerungen verletzt werden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren die
Union hat hier in diesem Hohen Hause
keinen der von mir genannten 18 anderen
Todesfälle von Radfahrer in Berlin zum
Anlass einer parlamentarischen Debatte
gemacht keine dabei gäbe es viel zu
diskutieren über bauliche Maßnahmen an
Kreuzungen zum Schutz von Radfahrern
über verpflichtende ablegerassistenten
an eine Effekt
ive des parkenden zweiter Reihe oder des
Gebots zur Rettungsgasse all diese
Debatten haben sie von der Union nicht
geführt nichts haben sie für den Schutz
von Radfahrern getan aber jetzt
aber jetzt faulenholz
wo sie einen Weg sehen den Tod einer
Radfahrerin einer politisch aus ihrer
Sicht missliebigen Gruppe
unterzuschieben fahren diese Kampagne
und diesen Antrag hier auf das ist
durchsichtig und gleichzeitig
um das klar zu sagen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen vor mir alle scheint es
auch schon zu Recht betont Protest darf
keine Menschenleben gefährden Punkt da
sind wir ganz klar aber man sollte auch
nicht pauschal behaupten dass er das tut
ohne die Fakten im Einzelfall zu
betrachten liebe Kolleginnen
hat es bereits ausgeführt wenn man ihrem
Antrag folgen würde dann würde jede
angemeldete legale friedliche
Demonstration auch die
treckerdemonstration die sie
ausdrücklich unterstützt haben in Sorge
darum sein ob nicht sie haftbar gemacht
werden für durch sie blockierte
rechnungswege eine solche
verfassungsfähige Einstellung der
Versammlungsfreiheit machen wir nicht
mit liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn
man die Union so hört könnte man meinen
der Rechtsstaat sei ein Holzhammer der
bedrohlich über den Köpfen der Menschen
schweben soll und sie quasi von
politisch unerwünschtem Verhalten
hindern soll das Gegenteil ist der Fall
der Rechtsstaat muss vor willküren vor
Übermaß Schützen der Rechtsstaat muss
für die Angemessenheit staatlicher
Maßnahmen einstehen und im Rechtsstaat
obliegt die abschließende juristische
Bewertung von Handlungen Gerichten und
nicht sehr Fraktionssitzung der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion sie
um es klar zu sagen das beschmieren der
Glasscheibe vor einem Gemälde mit
Kartoffelbrei finde ich unanständig
überflüssig und es spielt natürlich mit
der sorgung dieses Kunstwerkes spielt
mit den Ängsten der menschenweinliches
Kunstwerk aber es ist keine
Sachbeschädigung weil es die Substanz
eben nicht beschädigt egal was sie in
ihrer Anträge schreiben und um das
Blockieren einer Straße im Einzelfall
jedes Mal eine rechtswidrige Nötigung da
steht sie haben selber gesagt Herr
Krings das wird sehr unterschiedlich
bewertet es gab Verurteilung es gab aber
in der Tat auch Freisprüche insofern
gilt für euch weder hat es gesagt
vertrauen wir doch dem Rechtsstaat
vertrauen wir der Justiz unterstellen
wir nicht dauernd wie sie Union das tut
dass sie zu milde Sanktionen verhängen
würde sondern stärken wir die Gerichte
in ihrer Unabhängigkeit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich komme
ich komme zum Schluss Klimaschutz ist
nicht nur das Anliegen verschiedenste
Aktivistin auf der Straße sondern es ist
ein Verfassungsauftrag das hat das
höchste deutsche Gericht festgestellt
wir nehmen diesen Auftrag an wir wollen
Ihnen im parlamentarischen Wege mit
demokratischen Mitteln hier voranbringen
die Unionsfraktion ist herzlich
eingeladen ihre Blockadehaltung gegen
den Klimaschutz aufzugeben und ist dabei
zu begleiten aber wir werden notfalls
auch ohne sie veranstalten und diesen
Verfassungsauftrag die Freiheitsrechte
günstiger Generation zu wahren und zu
schützen dafür sind wir hier vielen Dank
es ist überraschend laut geworden hier
im Plenarsaal als Helge Limburg
gesprochen hat
ingma jung spricht nun als nächstes er
sitzt im Rechtsausschuss für die
Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin
meine Damen und Herren
Klima ist das Mega Thema der Gegenwart
und der nächsten Jahre wer politischer
Erfolg haben will und glaubt dass
ignorieren zu können dort keine Lösung
anzubieten der braucht eigentlich gar
nicht antreten ich glaube da sind wir
uns vollständig einig aber in Limburg
jetzt sage ich Ihnen auch wenn sie eben
erklärt haben die Union muss dafür ihre
Blockadehaltung aufgeben dann empfehle
ich Ihnen doch dringend nach meiner
Kenntnis hat die Ampel eine Mehrheit in
diesem Hause nutzen Sie doch die
Mehrheit die sie haben setzen Sie das
durch was sie für richtig halten und wir
schauen dann mal am Ende der
Legislaturperiode was sie erreicht haben
darauf kommt es auf uns leider nicht an
und meine Damen und Herren ich möchte
die sehr kurze Zeit nutzen um auf zwei
drei Sachen vielleicht einzugehen die
hier von Kollegen gesagt wurde Frau ich
will der Herr Kuhle und auch noch Herr
Limburg sie haben alle drei erklärt
strafzumessungs-
das ist völlig zutreffend deswegen sagt
unser an unser Antrag dazu auch kein
Wort denn das Festlegen des Strafrahmens
das Festlegen der Gesetze das ist Sache
des Gesetzgebers genau das beantragen
wir hier genau darüber wollen wir
diskutieren und das werden sie der
ersten Gewalt in diesem Staate doch auch
noch zugestehen bitteschön
und
Frau
Bünger hat uns vorgeworfen wir versuchen
die Diskriminierung politischer
Meinungsäußerung durchzusetzen also das
ist wirklich Leute das ist wirklich
sowas von absurd es geht doch genau um
das Gegenteil wir reden die heute über
Freiheitsrechte und die
strandgrenzen derselben und in
Rechtsstaaten das unterscheidet uns
gerade von Unrechtsstaaten da sind
Freiheitsrechte nur deshalb so viel wert
weil sie genau diskriminierungsfrei
gewährt werden und das muss aber auch
beiden Seiten gelten sie können in
Deutschland Freiheitsrechte für alles in
Anspruch nehmen sie können für jeden
Unsinn demonstrieren gehen und wir
entscheiden hier nicht ob das Ziel
richtig ist oder ob es uns passt oder
nicht das ist nämlich der Unterschied
zum autoritären Regime dann aber meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen dann
gilt auf der anderen Seite aber auch
dasselbe dann müssen die die staatlich
gesetzten strafrechtlichen Grenzen auch
völlig unabhängig vom Ansehen der
Position um Ansehen der Person
durchgesetzt werden ansonsten ist es
nämlich keine diskriminierungsfreie
Gewährung und genau darum geht es heute
und meine Damen und Herren Herr Fiedler
hat uns dann auch genauso wie Frau
eichwede vorher erklärt straf schaffen
ja sind strafschärfung Schrecken keinen
ab führen sowieso nicht dazu geschafft
hat nicht durchgeführt werden damit
stellen sie letztlich Strafrecht ganz
grundsätzlich in Frage aber der schönste
widerspruch kam ja dann im nächsten Satz
bei umweltstraftätern ist das natürlich
was anderes das ist doch genau die
Diskriminierung es gibt gute Straftäter
schlechte Straftäter bei den einen
brauchen höhere Strafen bei den anderen
nicht nein für uns ist das ohne
Anziehung der dahinterstehenden Position
und wir sagen klar an der Stelle wer
Freiheitsrechte ausübt der muss das
unbeschränkt tun können der hat den
vollen Schutz des Staates verdient der
will übrigens auch nicht gemein gemacht
werden mit den anderen aber wer
mutwillig vorsätzlich die Grenzen
überschreitet der ist eben Straftäter
und uns auch so behandelt werden und da
müssen wir hinkommen
[Applaus]
Kurzintervention oder was heißt ihre
Meldung
dann
gebe ich Ihnen das Wort für eine
Kurzintervention
ich habe mich glaube ich schon sehr
lange gemeldet und wurde abgesehen davon
in der Rede ja auch zweimal persönlich
angesprochen deshalb wollte ich zunächst
darauf eingehen dass nach dem Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion sonst können sie uns
vielleicht noch mal hellen ja
offensichtlich eine Unzufriedenheit mit
bisher durch strafrichterinnen und
Strafrichter verhängte Strafen besteht
sonst würden sie doch auch keine
Notwendigkeit sehen den Strafrahmen von
unten anzuheben und eben zu
Freiheitsstrafen ihrer Meinung
nachzukommen ich glaube ich habe da
gelegt dass das durch Paragraf 47 StGB
auch nach ihrem Antrag gar nicht möglich
wäre aber trotzdem wollen sie da doch in
die Kompetenzen und in die
Strafzumessung der Richterinnen und
Richter politisch eben entsprechend
Eingreifen wir sind hier keine
Notwendigkeit und die andere Sache weil
sie auch hinsichtlich der Rede des
Kollegen Fiedler gesagt wir haben dass
er sich hier selber widersprochen hätte
das hat er nicht werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir haben einfach kein
unternehmenssanktionsstrafrecht in
Deutschland das wollten wir schon lange
durchsetzen das war mit ihnen in der
großen Koalition nicht möglich von daher
würden wir hier dem Strafrecht und dem
Rechtsstaat eine weitere Möglichkeit
geben um gegen eines der größten
kriminalitätsfelder weiter vorzugehen
Herr Jung möchten sie reagieren
bitteschön
also
zunächst ich habe Ihre Meldung gesehen
ich hätte ihre Zwischenfrage auch
zugelassen ich wollte noch nicht gefragt
also sag nicht daran dass ich zugelassen
habe zum zweiten
habe ich den Kollegen Fiedler nicht so
verstanden dass er vom
unternehmensaktionsrecht gesprochen hat
sondern vom umweltstrasse sie haben von
Umweltstraftaten können wir gerne
Protokoll mal schauen ob ich es richtig
verstanden habe oder falsch dort haben
wir Strafrecht und an dem einen Teil ist
er davon ausgegangen dass härtere
Strafen helfen auf der anderen Seite ist
er davon ausgegangen dass sie nichts
bringen nur das habe ich zitiert da
können Sie andere Auffassung sein aber
das war genauso eben in der Debatte
und zum dritten wird die Frage unter die
Behauptung dass wir in die
Strafzumessung Eingriffen ja nicht
richtiger wenn man sie wiederholt kein
Teil unseres Antrags gibt Vorgaben für
die straf zu Messung und es ist ein
völlig neues tatdelikt ein Strafdelikt
dass wir oder ein Phänomen ein neues
dass wir gerade erleben in den letzten
Wochen und da muss es dem Gesetzgeber
doch gestattet sein darauf zu reagieren
und andere Strafrahmen festzulegen
nichts anderes macht unser Antrag an der
Stelle und weil sie jetzt zum
weil sie jetzt zum zweiten Mal den 47
zitieren er ist ja völlig richtig aber
genau deshalb sind wir doch auf die drei
Monate gegangen damit es uns doch auch
klar ist entstehen noch Fälle in denen
der Tatbestand erfüllt ist aber
möglicherweise eine Freiheitsstrafe doch
nicht gerechtfertigt ist damit lassen
wir den Gerichten doch die Flexibilität
wir haben intern ernsthaft darüber
diskutiert auf sechs Monate zu gehen
dann greift er nämlich nicht mehr die 47
und haben aber bewusst die drei Monate
gewählt weil wir damit am Ende auch noch
die Fälle in denen es nicht
gerechtfertigt ist ausschließen können
das ist wegen deswegen ist es ja am Ende
ein Kompromiss und eine flexible
pragmatische Lösung gewesen und deswegen
verstehe ich nicht warum sich dem nicht
anschließen kann
[Applaus]
Katrin Henning klar hat jetzt das Wort
für die FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren der Zweck heiligt nicht
nur nicht die Mittel mit dem falschen
Mittel schadet man ein eigentlich eher
waren Ziel sogar dem Beweis dafür hat
die letzte Generation wirklich
eindrücklich angetreten aber liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
ich zweifle sehr das Populismus und
Symbolpolitik hierauf die richtige
Reaktion ist
wenn es nicht nur um die schnelle
Schlagzeile gehen soll ist manchmal
weniger mehr denn wir können sehr
zuversichtlich sein dass die Justiz auf
das Phänomen Straßenblockade angemessen
zu reagieren weiß entsprechende
Straftaten müssen regelmäßig zu Anklage
gebracht und abgeurteilt werden bei
politisch motivierten Straftätern muss
der Rechtsstaat klar und frühzeitig
Grenzen aufzeigen der wiederholt andere
nötigt da muss mit Freiheitsstrafen
rechnen und zwar auch ohne Bewährung die
landesjustizminister sollten deshalb
klarstellen dass Strafverfahren im
Zusammenhang mit Straßenblockaden nicht
wegen Geringfügigkeit oder gegen
Auflagen und Weisungen eingestellt
sondern im Regelfall immer zur Anklage
gebracht und abgeurteilt werden
und auch bei der Abwägung der
Verhältnismäßigkeit von straßenräumungen
wird die Polizei die durch die Blockade
entstehende Gefahr für höchstrangige
Rechtsgüter wie Leib und Leben Dritter
nun stärker in ihre Entscheidung
einstellen müssen das alles gilt es
natürlich von Seiten der Politik eng zu
begleiten so sieht dann seriöse
Rechtspolitik aus anders die Union liebe
Kollegen von der Union zugute halten
kann man ihnen ja noch dass sie es in
der letzten Minute geschafft haben von
der Idee des präventiv Gewahrsams
Abstand zu nehmen immerhin leider ist es
aber auch das einzig Erfreuliche das ist
zu ihrem Antrag zu sagen gibt viele
grundsätzliche Dinge sind hier in der
Debatte ja schon genannt worden aber
auch handwerklich stimmt da bei ihrem
Antrag kaum etwas zwei Beispiele sie
wollen alle in §
304 STB genannten Gegenstände Zitat
besser vermutwilligen Beschädigungen
schützen und dazu Straftatbestand Zitat
anpassen in 304 StGB werden aber auch
Gegenstände die zu Verschönerung
öffentlicher wegeplätze oder Anlagen
dienen erfasst also mehrmonatige
Freiheitsstrafen für den dummen Jungen
der erstmalig ein Herz in eine Parkbank
ritzt oder denen der aus Wut gegen einen
Blumenkübel tritt ist dass Sie Ernst das
traue ich ihnen eigentlich nicht zu sie
wollen
§ 315b StGB so anpassen dass die Täter
bereits dann bestraft werden wenn eine
Blockade nur schon abstrakt dazu
geeignet ist Leib und Leben eines
Menschen zu gefährden ja liebe Union in
welchem Fall einer Demonstration ist es
nicht theoretisch denkbar dass ohne die
Demo weniger Stau bestünde nach Ihren
Vorstellungen wäre die bloße Teilnahme
an den bereits angesprochenen
bauerndemos im Mindestmaß mit
Freiheitsstrafe von drei Monaten zu
bestrafen dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht das in der
Abwägung mit dem Versammlungsrecht wohl
ohnehin nicht mitmachen dürfte das lasse
ich jetzt mal außen vor so weit haben
sie nämlich wohl ohnehin noch nicht
gedacht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir müssen der sogenannten letzten
Generation entgegentreten dazu aber gibt
das geltende Recht viel Spielraum dieser
muss genutzt werden wir brauchen
Konsequenz keinen Aktionismus vielen
Dank
Konsequenzen kein Aktionismus erfordert
Katrin Helling plant
und das lassen wir mal so stehen
Matthias Helferich ist fraktionslos
deswegen hält sich auch der Applaus in
Grenzen und schon am Rednerpult sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren mit dem
heutigen Antrag versucht die cdu/csu
zumindest vorzugeben ihre Wurzeln als
law and order-partei wieder zu entdecken
selbstverständlich nicht ohne zuvor ein
Kniefall vor dem grünen Zeitgeist zu
machen Straßen Blockierer und
museumsrandalierer der klingskriminelle
Protest kann auf das wohl Bauen von
ihnen allen dem politmedialen
establishmen Vertrauen das wissen auch
CDU und CSU und winseln daher gebrochen
von der grünen Übermacht radikaler
klimawand ja aber doch bitte innerhalb
rechtsstaatlich ergänzen das Problem
liegt derweil ganz woanders es ist die
Verschiebung rechtsstaatlicher Maßstäbe
in diesem Land würden die Straßen
Blockierer und museumskandalierer gegen
die anhaltende Massenmigration und für
den Erhalt ihrer nationalen Identität
demonstrieren würde das Establishment
geeint knapp Verfassungsschutz sek und
die terrorismusmaßnahmen rufen das taten
sie zum Beispiel alle bereits als
patriotische Aktivisten die
CDU-Parteizentrale besetzen das
Brandenburger torklum oder Banner am
Kölner Hauptbahnhof niedersiesen
friedlicher Protest von rechts wird von
ihnen allen kriminalisiert
links-neubauer musste nie mit der
Kündigung Ihres Kontos bis zur
Vernichtung ihrer sozialen Existenz
rechnen corona-maßnahmen Kritiker oder
Kritiker der Massenzuwanderung müssen
dies in diesem Lande regelmäßig der
radikale klimaprotest wenn sich sicher
an der Seite der mächtigen sie wissen
dass mancher Richter ihre Straftaten
bereits durch Paragraph 34 ist diegb
gerechtfertigt zieht begrüßenswert ist
dass die cdu/csu versucht sich selbst
wiederzufinden peinlich ist dass sie
sich in der Vergangenheit bei der
Diffamierung konservative Aktivisten
oder friedlicher Spaziergänger in einem
Überbietungswettbewerb mit all den
linken Kräften begeben haben die sie
heute versuchen zaghaft
kritisieren vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und da gibt es dann doch ein bisschen
Applaus aus der ehemaligen Fraktion von
Matthias Helferich der afd-fraktion
nächster Redner ist Robin mesaros
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren ich werde oft wütend
richtig wütend wenn ich Auto fahre da
reicht es dass jemand meine Spur
schneidet oder noch schlimmer 90 fährt
und dann werfe ich in meinem Auto
schlimmste Beleidigung um mich rum
sollte sich jemand auf die Straße kleben
vor meinen Weg wenn ich zur Arbeit muss
ich wird richtig ausrasten und wenn
Rettungswegen da behindert werden kann
ich verstehen das wird noch gefährlicher
sich verstehe jeden der da wütend ist
auch wenn sich bei mir gar niemand auf
die Straße klebt ehrlich gesagt was ich
aber nicht verstehe ist wenn Parteien
versuchen Wut auszunutzen weil sie damit
Stimmen sammeln wollen CDU und CSU
beantragen heute höhere Strafen für
klimaaktivist und Aktivisten ich will
ihnen erklären warum das auch für sie
gefährlich ist
erstens die kriminalwissenschaft sagt
ganz klar diese Erhöhung Schrecken nicht
ab bei höheren Strafen kriegen wir oft
höhere Rückfallquoten CDU und CSU würden
unser Land damit nicht sicherer machen
vielleicht sogar unsicherer
in den USA sind viel viel mehr Leute im
Gefängnis als in Deutschland aber
Deutschland ist es deutlich sicherere
Land Haftstrafen sind oft die falsche
Stellschraube verstehen Sie mich richtig
wer unsere Straßen blockiert und
Kunstwerke beschädigt muss bestraft
werden aber dafür haben wir schon
angemessene Strafen wenn wir in unserer
Strafrecht jetzt politisch eingreifen
kann es am Ende für uns alle gefährlich
werden Bayern hat vor fünf Jahren ein
gefährliches Gesetz eingeführt um
islamistische Gefährder zwei Monate in
Präventivhaft nehmen zu nehmen also um
Straftaten im Vorhinein verhindern zu
wollen wir haben dagegen demonstriert
und mussten uns anhören ihren
Terroristen den Schutz des unverschämt
inzwischen sitzen in München junge
klimaaktivistinnen Aktivisten in dieser
sogenannten Präventivhaft die doch
eigentlich für islamistische Terroristen
gedacht war Bayern will ein Zeichen
setzen jetzt stellen Sie sich mal vor
was wäre wenn die Herren von der AFD in
der Bundesregierung stellen wer da
weggesperrt würde lassen Sie mich ganz
deutlich sagen die letzte Generation tut
falsche rechtswidrige und gefährliche
Dinge aber in Deutschland dürfen wir nie
wieder Leute wegsperren nur weil es den
mächtigen politisch hilft das muss ganz
klar sein
die CDU will heute auch ein Zeichen
setzen sie seien der Schutzwall vor den
Chaoten dabei bringen sie das Chaos in
den Rechtsstaat im letzten Winter sind
bei mir in der Gegend die Montagsdemos
aus dem Ruder gelaufen in Albstadt
standen an unangemeldete querdenkerdemos
auch in den rettungszufahren der des
Krankenhauses wo waren die Forderungen
nach Strafverschärfung da oder wo waren
die Forderungen der Strafverschärfungen
als die Flüchtlingsheime brannten oder
anderes Beispiel wir hatten über 13.800
schwere Verkehrsunfälle letztes Jahr in
Deutschland weil Leute mit Rausch im
Kopf Auto gefahren sind keine Kampagne
der CDU da kann es sein dass es sich im
Bierzelt einfach besser gegen
Klimaschutz als gegen Alkohol hetzen
lässt anderes Beispiel alle vier Minuten
wird in Deutschland jemand Opfer von
Gewalt zu Hause in fast allen Fällen
sind das Frauen hier häufen sich die
Verbrechen was macht ihr
CDU-Vorsitzender bei seiner Parteitag
Rede erwähnt der diese Gewalt mit keiner
Silbe findet aber zweie paar Minuten
Zeit um übers Gendern zu philosophieren
anderes Beispiel sie hetzen seit zwei
Wochen gegen das Bürgergeld und wollen
das Leute die gerade ihren Job verloren
haben härtere Vorschriften bekommen
viele von ihnen hetzen dagegen dass
Leute die nichts haben in dieser Krise
53 Euro im Monat mehr bekommen aber wo
Millionäre Milliarden Euro an Steuergeld
hinterziehen jedes Jahr rechtswidrig
Geld das wir für straßenschulen und
Krankenhäuser bauen da gibt es keine CSU
Facebook Post gegen den Millionärs Liebe
CDU sie bekämpfen nicht das Chaos sie
schaffen hier Chaos lassen Sie mich
bitte mit zwei möchten Sie die
Zwischenfrage zulassen also gut
vielen Dank dass Sie die Zwischenfrage
zulassen ich habe nur eine Frage bleiben
Sie dabei dass die Union gegen das
Bürgergeld hetzt ja
[Applaus]
also ich hatte ja schon geantwortet ja
damit haben
gut wenn es immer so schnell ging lassen
Sie mich mit zwei bitten Enden erstens
an alle die zuschauen ich verstehe das
cdu/csu und AFD
ich glaube so schnell kommen nicht mehr
durch ich verstehe das cdu/csu und AFD
ihre Wut manchmal in den Bundestag
besser transportieren als wir wir teilen
ihre Wut aber wir finden der Bundestag
wo Gesetze entstehen ist vielleicht der
falsche Ort für Wut wo wir aus Wut
unsere Justiz beeinflussen schaffen wir
Chaos und ein chaotischer Rechtsstaat
kann auch sie gefährden auch wenn sie
gar nichts tun und nicht nur die CDU und
CSU Handeln aus Wut sondern die
sogenannte letzte Generation auch es ist
in beiden Fällen falsch und es ist dumm
Leute wütend auf den Klimaschutz zu
machen wo wir die Zustimmung brauchen
seien sie klug ich klebe meine Hand
nirgends fest sondern hebe sie im
Bundestag für die größte Reform des
erneuerbaren Energien Gesetz der
Geschichte der Rechtsstaat braucht kein
cdu-populismus der Klimaschutz braucht
auf der Straßen Blockierer lassen Sie
die Wut im Bauch und uns Probleme wieder
mit dem Kopf lösen haben sie vielen Dank
Robin mesar Rosch hat hier auch deutlich
die Union angegriffen direkt darauf
antworten kann und Christiane
schenderlein wenn sie möchte sie sitzt
für die Unionsfraktion im Ausschuss für
Kultur und Medien
ach aber zuerst gibt es noch eine
Kurzintervention aus der afd-fraktion
zulassender Kurzintervention wäre auch
nett wenn der Kollege dann zuhört was in
der Debatte allgemein insbesondere bei
den Rednern der schuldenkoalition
aufgefallen ist das überhaupt nicht die
Bedeutung des Rechtsstaates und von
Gesetzen auch bei Herrn Fiedler erkannt
haben ja sie können sich natürlich um
die täterwelt und die tätermotive und es
sind hier Straftäter kümmern aber ich
glaube unser Rechtssystem und unser
Rechtsstaat sollte auch eine andere
Wirkung noch entfalten für die vielen
Menschen da draußen die rechtschaffend
entsprechend auch das Versprechen
einlösen dass der Staat für Recht und
Ordnung in diesem Lande sorgt sie
kümmern sich wie immer in der linken
Szene ausschließlich um die Täter und
suchen jeden Grund und jedes Motiv ihn
zu entschuldigen das hat man bei Ihnen
auch gehört aber die Menschen die
betroffen sind und dass sind ihr gerade
in der Themenwoche was hält ein Land
zusammen dann sind das gemeinsame Norm
und das ein solches rechtswidriges
Verhalten für die Menschen die hier alle
von der cdu/csu eben genannt worden sind
auch von unseren Rednern sanktioniert
werden muss und selbstverständlich wenn
sie aufgeben das Strafen Abschreckung
haben sollen oder keine Abschreckung
entfalten sollen dann packen Sie doch
gleich ein das ist eine Kapitulation
selbstverständlich und dann ist in
unserem Staat etwas falsch müssen
Strafen und der rechtskatalog auch
abschrecken wirken wenn Sie das Aufgeben
meine Damen und Herren dann lösen sie
den Rechtsstaat und das Vertrauen in die
Gerichte wie es die Kollegin von der SPD
wunderbar vorgemacht hat auf und deshalb
kommen die Anfragen und die Umfragen
zustande dass die Menschen da draußen
das Vertrauen in den Rechtsstaat
verloren haben und die müssen wir wieder
erreichen und das lassen sie hier in
ihren Betrachtungen völlig außen vor und
da bin ich wirklich entsetzt
möchten Sie Antworten das ist nicht der
Fall dann gebe ich jetzt das Wort an die
Kollegin Dr Christiane schendelein für
die CDU CSU-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Tomatensuppe auf van Gogh Kartoffelbrei
auf Monet das ist leider kein kreativer
Titel eines Kinderbuches nein das sind
reale Bilder die wir in den letzten
Wochen ertragen mussten und die nicht
nur bei Kunstliebhabern für Entsetzen
gesorgt haben sogenannte
klimaaktivisten werfen ausgerechnet mit
Lebensmitteln auf wertvolle Kunstwerke
und diese Attacken diese Angriffe sind
Angriffe auf unser kulturelles Erbe das
ist kein Aktivismus das ist Vandalismus
und ich möchte dafür
auch die juristische Definition zitieren
Kultur vandalismus ist die mutwillige
Zerstörung oder Beschädigung von
Kulturgütern im weitesten Sinne ist
damit jede Art von Handlung gemeint die
mit Vorsatz oder billigungen dazu führt
dass Kunstwerke Schaden nehmen oder
unwiederbringlich zerstört werden und
die Angriffe sind eben vorsätzlich und
sie nehmen die Beschädigung von
Kunstwerken in Kauf und deshalb sind
diese Menschen keine Aktivisten sondern
kulturkulturbandalen sie begehen
Straftaten und diese müssen mehr folgen
haben als eine verbale Empörung und
marginale Geldstrafen
hier muss der Rechtsstaat konsequent
reagieren und mit unserem Antrag wollen
wir ihm genau dafür die notwendigen
Instrumente an die Hand geben sich
morgens aus Protest gegen
Lebensmittelverschwendung auf die Straße
kleben und nachmittags dann mit
Lebensmitteln auf Gemälde werfen das ist
verrückt bisher gab es ein
gesellschaftlichen Konsens das unser
nationales Kulturerbe und Weltkulturerbe
geschützt werden muss und dieser wird
mit Radikalität aufgekündigt der
Deutsche museumsbund hat zu Recht von
einer Instrumentalisierung gesprochen
und bereits angekündigt dass mehr
Sicherheit und Personal notwendig sind
aber wer soll das bezahlen diese
Kunstwerke Meisterwerke gehören zu
unserem Kulturerbe und es sind Erbstücke
so wie in einer Familie da gibt es auf
der einen Seite den materiellen Wert
gemessenen Euro aber diese Werke haben
einen unschätzbaren ideellen Wert weil
sie uns erzählen woher wir kommen und
wer wir sind
[Applaus]
die letzte Generation bezeichnet sich
selbst als Überlebenswille dieser
Gesellschaft doch wir brauchen auch
unsere Kultur unsere Identität zum
Überleben in der Präambel der
hagerkonvention zum Schutz von Kulturgut
von 1954 steht die Überzeugung dass jede
Schädigung von Kulturgut gleichgültig
welchem Volk er es gehört eine
Schädigung des kulturellen Erbes der
ganzen Menschheit bedeutet
eine Zwischenfrage zulassen dass ich bin
schon beim letzten Satz
abschließend steht fest mit dem Angriff
auf unsere Kultur werden wir die Welt
auf keinen Fall retten
vielen Dank
damit gebe ich
damit gebe ich Lukas Benner das Wort für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
das war eine in Teilen skurrile Debatte
teilweise
unerträgliche Beiträge von dieser Seite
aber noch skurriler ist sie Antrag wenn
wir uns einmal anschauen dass sie den
größten Blödsinn nämlich die
Wiederholungsgefahr und damit die
Präventivhaft zum Glück herausgestrichen
haben macht das leider den restlichen
Antrag nicht besser und ich glaube es
ist selbst ihren eigenen Leuten peinlich
wenn wir uns angucken der öffentlich
sagt dass das was sie hier fordern nicht
angemessen ist schauen wir uns den Kern
an im Kern fordern sie die Erhöhung von
Freiheitsstrafe das ist rechtspolitisch
Unsinn und da verweise ich vor allen
Dingen auf meine Vorrednerinnen und
Vorredner von der SPD die sehr schön
ausgeführt haben das vor allen Dingen
kurze Freiheitsstrafen völlig
wirkungslos sind aber es ist auch
rechtsdogmatisch Unsinn ich verweise
wieder auf Frau Kollegin eichwedel die
sehr schön den 47,1 StGB hier vorgeführt
hat
unintelligible
schauen wir uns einmal schauen wir uns
doch einmal an welches Regelbeispiel sie
bei 240 also der Nötigung hier fordern
sie schreiben in ihrem Antrag dass
ebenso Täter bestraft werden sollen die
eine große Zahl von Menschen durch ihre
Blockade nötigen etwa dann wenn es durch
die Blockaden im Berufsverkehr zu langen
Stau kommen das bedeutet sie wollen
Menschen härter bestrafen die ohne
irgendjemanden zu gefährden lange Staus
verursachen der Gesetzgeber ist auch an
das Schuldprinzip gebunden das heißt
auch wir als Gesetzgeber müssen dafür
sorgen dass eine der Tat angemessene
Strafe verhängt wird schauen wir uns
doch einmal an wo man sonst drei Monate
bis fünf Jahre Haft verhängt das ist zum
Beispiel sexueller Missbrauch von
Schutzbefohlenen tägliche Angriffe auch
von streckungsbeamte gefangeneneuterei
wollen Sie ernsthaft sagen dass wir
denselben Strafrahmen für das
Herbeiführen von Staus brauchen das kann
doch nicht geernt sein das ist völlig
unverhältnis
meine Damen und Herren ich habe in den
letzten Tagen immer wieder zu diesem
Thema gehört wir brauchen die volle
Härte des Rechtsstaats es muss mit
voller Härte durchgegriffen werden den
Rechtsstaat immer nennt ist dass er für
alle gleich gilt und zwar allein auf
Basis von Recht und Gesetz das mag
langweilig klingen in der politischen
Debatte aber es ist doch genau der Kern
der Rechtsstaat ist ein Rechtsstaat und
der kennt keine volle Härte
das Strafrecht ist das schärfste Schwert
was wir hier zur Verfügung haben und man
schwingt es nicht je nach Stimmung im
Bierzelt und man schwingt es nicht wenn
es einem gerade passt denn wenn das
Strafrecht zum Spielball für politischen
Aktionismus wird dann ist das ein
Schritt zur Willkür vielen Dank
Lukas Benner war hier der letzte Redner
in der Debatte zum Antrag der
Unionsfraktion die hier fordert für
Personen die die Straße blockieren oder
im Museum wie es doch häufig vorgekommen
ist oder in letzter Zeit vorgekommen ist
Kunstwerke beschmutzt haben dass es für
die härtere Strafen geben soll dieser
Antrag wird jetzt an die entsprechenden
Ausschüsse über